customers make a decision of how good a
business is within the first 48 Hours
think about what happens in The First 48
hours in your business do you just sell
someone and they get no communication
happens all the time I know cuz I buy
too what you want to do is make lots of
micro promises and meet those promises
as you said you would and so you say hey
you're going to get an email within the
next 30 minutes it's going to have these
things on it 2 hours later you're going
to get a call from Angie tomorrow
morning I'm going to set you up with
Sandra and then from there you should
expect your ads to go live the next day
guess what happens the next day they get
a notification the moment their ads go
live we set three or four micro
expectations and we've met every single
one of them